here's something you're going to love or
hate the 2017 range rover evoque
convertible this is the soft top version
of the small luxury crossover SUV that
range rover debuted a few years ago it's
the first convertible SUV that range
rover has ever made and the company says
the first modern luxury convertible SUV
ever this will definitely be a
polarizing vehicle some people are going
to love it because it's quirky and weird
and it's an odd shape and some people
are going to hate it because it's quirky
and weird and it's an odd shape Land
Rover made it to tap into the growing
luxury SUV market and to piggyback on
the considerable success that the evoke
has had since its inception it looks
like the original evoke except for a few
minor aesthetic changes on the front and
the addition of alloy wheels LED fog
lamps and some cool tech features inside
it comes with a black fabric top that
deploys in about 18 seconds I like that
this convertible has considerable room
in the trunk more than most plus it has
to roll over protection bars that will
pop out at a milliseconds notice if you
happen to flip this thing the evoke
convertible has the same 240 horsepower
four-cylinder engine and 9-speed
automatic transmission as its hardtop
sister it comes with an active drive
that will switch between front and
all-wheel drive depending on road
conditions and we'll go to 60 miles per
hour in 7.8 seconds so it's not the
fastest SUV ever but it's fast enough
and if you're the type to want a beefy
open-top ride that sits high like an SUV
but feels luxurious enough inside to
cruise down Rodeo Drive this is the one
for you pricing will start around 52
thousand dollars